[موسيقى]
ما يقرب من 50 عامًا بعد أن قام المصور غزير الإنتاج
مارتن باثس بتدريب عدسته لأول مرة
على الحياة والثقافة البريطانية
بأسلوبه الفكاهي والواقعي المفرط ،
تجد الأمة نفسها نفسها في
لحظة حرجة من التأمل الذاتي
تتساءل عن فكرة ما
يعنيه ذلك  أن أكون بريطانيًا ، فأنا أحب هذا
البلد ومع ذلك منزعج منه ، فأنت تعلم أنني من
الباقي الكلاسيكي ، لذلك كنت
منزعجًا للغاية ومنزعجًا من عملية خروج بريطانيا بأكملها ،
لذا فإن هذا هو التوتر الذي أشعر به
عندما أنظر إلى بريطانيا أحاول أن أفكر فيه.
الصور الفوتوغرافية ،
لذا فهو يشبه شكلًا من أشكال
العلاج الذي رآه شكل من أشكال العلاج على قدم المساواة
كواحد من أبرز
مؤرخي بوتقة الانصهار الثقافي
في المملكة المتحدة ، ربما تكون
ثلاثة أرباع مليون نسخة من
طباعاتي Walternate بوصة من طريق العودة من
الصور بالأبيض والأسود من خلال اثنين من
السلبيات الملونة تفعل لمعرفة أيًا كان
النهج الصريح العام الذي يجلب
ميزة ساخرة إلى السؤال المعقد
للهوية البريطانية ، لذلك عندما
أقوم بالتصوير ، أبحث تقريبًا
عن قصة صغيرة لقصة صغيرة حيث
سيكون هناك بعض التوتر وبعض
الغموض ، وبعض التناقضات
شيء مثبت لتعليق القصة حقًا
لأنك تعلم أن الصور يجب أن يكون لها
نوع من المعنى  المعنى يجب أن
يكون لديهم بعض الإحساس بصدام إذا كنت
تحب غموض التوتر في الصراع ، كل
الموضوعات المألوفة للمساواة أعتقد أن
بريطانيا تتغير لأن السياسة في
المستقبل لا أعرف ما إذا كان سيتم تقسيم الوقت في غضون عشر سنوات
في الطريق  بين
الإجازة والبقاء على عكس قول العمل
واليسار والمحافظة واليمين ، لذا
فهذا هو الشيء المناسب حقًا
للاستيلاء عليه ،
هذا محل جزار وأعتقد أن
الشيء الذي يجعل هذا العمل هو اليد
التي تنزل من الجزار وتردد صدى
النقانق لك  أعلم أنك بحاجة إلى
شيء ما في الصورة
يعطينا نوعًا ما نقرة ، مما يمنحه
صوتًا رائعًا على الصور المتعرجة التي دائمًا ما تخلق
ضجة ، لكنه يؤكد مثل العديد من الفنانين
أن دوره بسيط  للتوثيق
والاستمتاع بعدم الإدلاء بتصريحات سياسية ،
يأتي الجميع بأمتعتهم الخاصة
إلى الصور التي تعرف أنني
لن أغير وجهة نظرك حول
أي شيء سياسي أو على جبهة خروج بريطانيا من الاتحاد الأوروبي
أو ما إذا كان إلى أي مدى
تريد دعم المناخ  تمرد التغيير أو
التمديد لن أكون
قادرًا على إخبارك بذلك ولكن إذا كان لديك
آرائك وتحيزاتك وأمتعتك ،
فستتمكن من العثور على
حجج داخل صوري لدعمها
[تصفيق]